sorry am i late
um yes you it really you are but it
doesn't
you look thank you
oh allow me to get these for you
well this would be fun know i love the
reclamation center at this time of day
don't you
what the colors so it's the cremation
process the the red color i believe is
uh phosphorus or it could be aerosol
particle scattering of sunlight
which happens when they're the same size
as the wavelength of the radiation
smoke sense there do you see
shorter wavelengths can't get through no
blues no greens or uc is what's left
the remaining light longer wavelengths
and it's red
is it your first time
there's nothing to it
[Music]
excuse me
do you see that ah
here we are
[Music]
every alpha goes to the savage lands of
that age
why the lord wants to stake
[Music]
when you ask someone to care for their
health for society it um
makes quite an impression to show them a
dead one first
oh wait what is it stand by for launch
in four three two
one
i had a bench there's no network nothing
can reach up here not even injured
[Music]
these new ones did cause me some concern
amazing
it's amazing
you must try this oh do you leave me all
the way back
lily you have to come down and i see
but we are clearing aputure as we speak
and you really need it done
[Music]
ready
[Music]
you